[Music]
foreign
yeah Kiki Palmer's a triple threat and
her latest Talent speaking things into
existence
[Music]
while reflecting on the past year over
the weekend she shares a clip of her
biggest life change in 2023. her baby
boy leotis
[Music]
alongside the precious mother-son moment
Kiki looks back at her life one year ago
and to think just last April fools I
joked about being preggers yeah fans
might recall Kiki's prank when she
posted eight now deleted mirror selfie
writing I've officially joined the mom
Club
and as she holds leotis Kiki would be
remiss if she didn't point out we
manifested you little buddy
[Music]
Kiki and boyfriend Darius Jackson
welcomed little Leo to the world in
February
there's some rooms going around two
months after fans first learned about
Kiki's manifestation during her Saturday
Night Live monologue people have been in
my comments saying Kiki's having a baby
Kiki's pregnant and I want to set the
record straight I am
this has been the biggest blessing and I
am so excited guys I'm gonna be a mom
oh my gosh yes
[Music]
Kiki adds to her message telling Leo I
love hanging with you meanwhile he's
already tired of me come on let's talk
about it after all Leo who Mom and Dad
nicknamed mukimuk has seen plenty of
excitement for being a newborn like his
sweet stroll in the Big Apple last month
[Music]
the New York City skyline inspired Kiki
to call being a mom her greatest gig of
all I just came on here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape she's also been
honest about the moments that aren't so
picture perfect because I know there's a
million and one reasons why somebody
wants to be a single parental but when
it comes to raising a kid I've already
learned in these short few days that
it takes a village she doubles down on
that in the caption quote I ain't gonna
lie I'm getting cooked and I just want
anybody out there that is a single
parent that's been doing this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart
bring tears to my eyes I am just truly
profoundly impressed
you have my respect sister
[Music]